so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about Hulk the last man on
earth or as it's most commonly known
Hulk the end and what I'm hoping is that
by the end of this video you'll have an
understanding of why this story was
created and more specifically why I and
other people in the comic-book community
consider it to be one of the best
Incredible Hulk stories ever written
so hope the end was a one-shot written
in 2002 by Peter David as part of the
Marvel the end series these comics which
included one shots for Punisher and Tony
Stark as well as a limited series for
Wolverine the Fantastic Four and others
Chronicle the last days of these
characters in a possible future some of
which deal with nuclear fallout while
others reflect the natural order of
things
now because there isn't much information
on why Hulk the end was written but
we're going to do here is jump into a
bit of speculation and conjecture and
what I mean is that while there have
been several character arcs like Hulk
Parton and ho progression these stories
can all be broken down into three main
components Hulk gets angered hook fight
someone and then Hulk calms down as a
result of these formulaic stories many
fans came to the belief that the
Incredible Hulk suffered from the
Superman complex and that the question
had to be asked how many stories can
truly be made involving the Incredible
Hulk to provide a deep measure of
insight into the character himself in an
effort to break away from this standard
of Hulk storytelling what I'd like to
believe is that Marvel wanted to present
us as the reader with a question what
would happen if everything The
Incredible Hulk knew and loved were
suddenly stripped away and the
incredible hope was left as the last
human on the planet Earth
the so hope the end picks up with Bruce
Banner providing a kind of narrative
where he gives us an initial indication
of the world around him and as a story
progresses what we'll actually find is
that we'll get more information as
things go on now what Bruce Banner
initially does is reflect on the idea of
past Wars saying that World War one was
called the war to end all wars and that
World War two assured in the Atomic Age
and the opening of a Pandora's box that
simply just couldn't be closed this
sentiment is further compounded on when
Banner tells us that while he hasn't
travelled the entire world what he has
done is traveled the length of the
entire North American continent from the
tip of Canada all the way down to the
bottom of South America and the only
thing that he's been witness to is
what's left of society in terms of
decaying building and dying plants as
well as insects basically taking over
everything in addition to this banner
expresses a desire to actually die here
something that he's simply been unable
to do because the Incredible Hulk won't
let him now we'll get into that
discussion here in the next few minutes
but what this story does is it
transitions away from Bruce banners
narrative and to the Incredible Hulk
himself and The Incredible Hulk seems to
be driven by two things the first is his
desire to be left alone and the second
is his hatred of Bruce Banner like
modern-day comparisons between the two
the Hulk views Banner as a weakness that
he would rather eliminate them put up
with banners desire to die is referred
to by the Hulk as a puny human thought a
weakness that only weak men would
succumb to furthermore the Hulk doesn't
seem to grasp the fact that he and
banner are two parts of a whole and then
it seems impossible for banner to
physically leave The Hulk and so the
hoax and ability to recognize this fact
drives his anger keeping him from being
at peace is effectively a vicious cycle
now from here the story continues with
banners narrative as he gives us the
backstory to the world as it exists now
somewhere along the line at least as he
explains it to us a memorial was made
for the various superheroes of Earth
after the hell on earth war
the outer world war following these two
conflicts a rogue insurgents group
managed to get its hands on a nuclear
weapon
now while the details are left a little
ambiguous here what seems to have
happened is that this rogue group
launched a nuclear attack sparking a
global thermonuclear war wiping out
virtually all life on the planet except
for the Hulk a few plants that happen to
be dying as well as a multitude of
insects which have grown to a gigantic
size in addition to this Bennett tells
us that the Hulk seemed to enjoy
watching humanity destroy itself even
going so far as saying that this fiery
end was something that was deserved and
that while it all happened
the only concern the Hulk had was simply
being the strongest there is
and being left alone now banner story
continues as he explains it during the
nuclear bombardment the Hulk actually
took refuge in a cave for an unknown
amount of time even banner himself
expressed his concern over whether it
was days months or years but what he
does say is that after everything was
over that the Incredible Hulk had
basically reverted back to his Bruce
Banner form and Bruce Banner was
awakened by the arrival of a robot from
one of the other races outside the
planet Earth in the Marvel Universe and
had this robot was basically exploring
or investigating the planet Earth
following the destruction of humanity
what the robot does here is it confirms
Bruce Banner suspicions that everything
is gone that every single human on the
planet Earth has gone with the exception
of him but he is in fact the last man on
earth the robot also tells Bruce Banner
that humanity had been considered a
nuisance by most of the alien races
within the Marvel Universe and the
following is destruction these races had
basically assured in their own errors of
peace and celebrating the fall of humans
but following this revelation Bruce
Banner had actually attempted to kill
himself on several occasions but each
time he tried the Hulk would emerge
believing the banner was basically
trying to kill him as well and so this
again ultimately added fuel to the fire
of why it was the Incredible Hulk hated
Bruce Banner so much now jumping from
this backstory and into the present day
we pick up with banner as he has a dream
of a woman appearing to be Betty Ross
now during this dream Vanna perceives
what he believes to be paradise
that the world's beautiful that the
grass is green and the sky is very very
blue furthermore banner tells us that
this woman whispers in his ear stating
that they will be gods and they'll
actually repopulate the planet earth
indicating that perhaps this is a
paradises source or the very least this
is a chance for Bruce Banner to start
over but after waking up from his dream
banners actually thrown back into this
very harsh reality of this dying world
but the dream itself sticks with him the
dream simply just lingers with him and
so banners belief here is that if he can
only die that he could basically achieve
eternal happiness in heaven alongside
the friends that he lost so long ago but
the Incredible Hulk who is continuously
fuelled by his hatred of banner simply
will not let this happen he simply tells
banner that he's never going to let
Bruce Banner die now in the midst of
this inner turmoil Bruce Banner appears
to actually have a heart attack and
while he continues to express a desire
to join Captain America spider-man Thor
and others in the afterlife as the
heroes of old hope believes that banners
heart attack is his attempt to finally
kill off the hook and so the inner
conflict between the two seems to come
to a boil when the Hulk declares that he
doesn't want to have friends and that
friends will betray him and that
ultimately he just wants to be left
alone and so at this point the story
picks up the following night with the
Incredible Hulk declaring that he's
finally rid himself of Bruce Banner
although we're not told how and so what
we find is that the Hulk realizes that
he's ultimately alone here that once
it's all said and done that once Bruce
Banner is gone that while the Incredible
Hulk is the strongest there is
and while he is the only one there is
that he's very very cold meaning that
he's very very lonely
so while there isn't much information on
Hulk V and after its release the
information I've been able to gather is
that the story was met with universal
acclaim from virtually all media outlets
from IGN to casual comic fans as well as
hardcore Incredible Hulk readers The
Hulk the end was a story that so many
people had been wanting for they've been
waiting for a story chronicling the life
of Bruce Banner and the Hulk without a
formulaic hot they gave a deep amount of
character insight into what drives the
Hulk and his relationship and hatred
with Bruce Banner and what I mean here
is that over the course of the
incredible Hawks publication history and
Marvel Comics we've seen instances where
by he's indicated how much he hates
Bruce Banner and we've seen instances
where the two of them who come into
conflict but we've never seen a story
where Marvel has wiped the entire
landscape where they said that
everything that could influence hoaxes
anger towards Bruce Banner has been
removed leaving only Hulk and Bruce
Banner to deal with each other and
that's what this story does this story
basically tells us that while Bruce
Banner simply wants a release while he
wants to leave while he wants to go to
heaven while he wants to spend eternity
with those that he loves that the
Incredible Hulk is unable to let go of
his hatred unable to let go of past
betrayals and that even if it means
condemning himself to a life of solitude
and misery The Incredible Hulk will
continue to do this that he will
continue to hold on to the one thing he
hates most and that is the concept of
Bruce Banner and the fact that people in
the past albeit those individuals being
gone have betrayed him
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later peace